intensificando la presión los
agricultores indios se han declarado en
huelga de hambre
queremos dar este mensaje al gobierno
que los que damos de comer a este país
nos sentimos hambrientos por sus
políticas los granjeros del norte han
acampado en la capital por las últimas
tres semanas manifestándose contra las
reformas en el sector de la agricultura
que dicen amenazar ya su supervivencia
la polémica se centra en torno a la
suavización de las normas de la venta el
precio y almacenamiento de los productos
agrícolas de seguir adelante las nuevas
leyes terminarían con los precios
garantizados de alimentos como el trigo
y el arroz pero también permitiría la
venta a empresas privadas ya que ahora
los granjeros venden sus productos a
precios fijados los economistas dicen
que esta reforma es un reto complejo en
este caso estamos viendo al gobierno
retirándose sobre lo que apoyaron y
diciéndole al mercado que haga lo mismo
pero la experiencia con la anterior
intervención del mercado es clara ellos
van a estar felices bajando los precios
antes que ayudando porque no quieren
ningún recorte en los subsidios
los granjeros sostienen que las reformas
los dejarían expuestos ante un gran
negocio mientras que el gobierno asegura
que estas duplicarían sus ganancias
claro está que las reuniones entre los
dos bandos no han dado sus frutos y las
protestas están lejos de acabar